[Music]
when I was 23 I was working at Good
Morning America and I had just been
promoted to the field and series unit
which was the unit where you could go
out into the field and produce pieces
and do live remotes and they were called
chutes and it was a dream come true one
of the first assignments that came up
was to go and produce a remote at the
field of dreams
now who by show of hands remembers the
movie of Field of Dreams okay that's
pretty good so we all knows with Kevin
Costner
it's a magical movie about baseball and
there's a real baseball field in the
middle of a cornfield right
I had no competition though for this
assignment because it was July 4th
weekend a three-day weekend and
everybody wanted Friday off so they're
like Alison you can go to Dubuque Iowa
and produce the remote so being a New
York City girl I had to go and I had to
rent a car which was not great for me I
wasn't a big driver and my mom was not
happy but I was more worried about
getting lost because I'm not great with
directions since I'm in New York her and
I grew up on a grid but I flew into
Dubuque I rented my car I went to the
farm I met Don Larson who was the farmer
and it looked exactly like my picture
and I figured out what all my shots
would be for the next morning and I was
so excited went back to the Best Western
the next morning I got up at 3:30 in the
morning gave myself a half an hour to
get to the site because with Good
Morning America you need to be there
three hours before to get set up with
the satellite trucks so as I'm driving
to the site it's pitch black and I had
no idea how dark it would be on rural
roads and I'm driving and trying to
remember my way to this farm and the air
condition was just blasting on me so I
went to turn it off but being an
inexperienced driver while I turned it
off this arm also parroted those moves
and I swerved off the road I hit the
accelerator instead of the brake and my
panic careened off the road hit
something and my car flipped twice and
then just kept going until it stopped in
the middle of a field at 3:30 in the
morning on a holiday weekend before
cellphones existed so when the car
stopped I looked down the door was open
and everything above my right my left
leg
above the muscle was sliced open and
sitting in my lap hanging by some skin
and my first thought was my mom is going
to kill me my second thought was I just
can't sit here and bleed to death I
gotta do something about this so I put
my leg back on I took my shirt off I
tied up my leg and I got out of the car
I started screaming the God God please
help me god I'm scared and then I said
okay I've done that and I figured I'd
start walking but all of a sudden I
remembered this dark curtain going down
on me and when I came to I was crouched
on the ground near my car and I remember
saying Alison if you pass out you're
gonna die
no one is going to find you get up so I
got up and the miracle was actually
making way my way back to the road
because I'm terrible with directions but
I made it back and I figure I'm gonna
walk til I get help go to a farm
eventually a car stopped it was Randy in
a red car going fishing and he stopped
and I went up to his window and I said
hi my name is Alison I'm going to a
shoot I haven't been shot I'm from Good
Morning America and he said I'm not from
here and I said I'm not either I need
your help so he pushed the door open and
I came around the front of the car and I
got in and then he closed the door and
then he saw that I was really damaged
and he told me later he just was so
frightened by seeing me come out of
nowhere I'm not sure my hair was a mess
it's bleeding so he goes I know
paramedic five towns away so he drove
and at that point I remember my shirt
was completely soaked with blood went
down to my ankle I'm bleeding all over
his car and I'm apologizing for his
upholstery and the next stop is there's
a man in a blue robe running towards my
window he goes the ambulance is on its
way I kind of went in and out of
consciousness then the ambulance came
they're putting braces on me they have
no idea I've been walking I said you
need to call Don Larson at this number
and tell him I'm not showing up for the
shoot you need to call my mother at this
number she's gonna be really pissed off
and now you need to give me a painkiller
and they said we can't give you that and
I said well then I'm not going to talk
to you and they were rolling me into the
ambulance and it was then that it
occurred to me what did I do to myself
how much damage did I do so I looked up
in this guy's face and I said
am I gonna be okay and he said I hope so
and I remember thinking that's the wrong
answer so even then I'm trying to
produce this poor guy so what ended up
happening is I stayed in Iowa for a week
they sewed my leg back on it died
everything above the muscle had been
severed all the nerves that turned black
ABC flew me back to New York in a
private plane I was in the hospital for
six weeks they removed the whole portion
of my leg they skin grafted from my butt
I had a bone graft into my arm which was
broken in three places and dislocated I
had broken ribs I had injured my
pancreas I had cuts and scrapes but my
seat belt had saved my life from going
through the roof of the car now I was in
I was in therapy for two years to regain
all my movement and you think okay this
is pretty traumatic but the most
traumatic part was that I lied about the
accident I told people I had swerved to
avoid hitting an animal because I was so
worried about my reputation I was
worried that I had messed up my first
big assignment and that they would never
give me another assignment at Good
Morning America
and I lived with this lie for years and
it was like an anvil on my chest and
what I didn't realize was that they
didn't care how I got into the accident
they cared how I got out of the accident
and that my reputation was fine because
people knew me as someone who was a
problem solver and reliable and friendly
and eager to do the work and that was a
hard lesson for me to learn and it's
always made me very interested in
reputation and how you overcome
obstacles and how you are consistent
with your messaging and as a lot of
people know we'll definitely Devon knows
that I teach reputation management here
so that story there's a reason I told
you that story one hopefully it caught
your attention and none of you were on
your cell phones
- it kind of showed you a life-changing
moment and how I how it informed me
moving on it showed how I deal with
adversity it showed the origin story of
creating a reputation management it was
memorable and it's a story that only I
can tell when you tell a story but
you're basically saying is I want you to
know me I want you to know who I am and
what I believe in and why I do what I do
and what my strengths are and what my
quirks are what differentiates me from
somebody else
and you're trying to prove your
credibility by showing your history when
you're creating your own narrative I
feel it's really important to start with
a story because it's so much more
interesting than data and facts did you
know that in a presentation you can only
take away two to three facts but you can
remember an entire story and if you can
control your own narrative others won't
fill in gaps that you've left open
also you can someone can carry your
store if you tell it succinctly and and
powerfully to someone else and that
could create opportunities for you
because then maybe you'll find a mentor
or an investor or a colleague it also is
a great way to connect to the audience
and it shows you at your most authentic
self so what makes a great story well
you want it to be rich in detail you
want it to be differentiated
authentically you and hopefully inspire
somebody a lot of times you want to
solve a problem and that's where your
origin story comes in because whatever
you're doing in life we need to show
people why you care and where the idea
came from who here knows about TOMS
shoes okay most of you right there just
canvas shoes they're like a thousand
canvas shoes all over but what made toms
so special well his story so blake
Makowski I thought if I'm pronouncing
the makovski he was on The Amazing Race
which is a reality show where you go to
different countries and you do
challenges and he was partnered with his
sister and one of the stops was
Argentina and when he was there he
noticed they had these shoe
call a legatos which were little canvas
shoes and when he finished the Amazing
Race he now had some money and some
notoriety but he never forgot Argentina
and he went back a few years later and
he saw a lot of the kids running around
without shoes and they were getting
their feet scraped and they were
spreading disease and he wanted to do
something of value so he decided he was
going to create a shoe company based on
the Alpen or Gatos and he was gonna call
it TOMS which means shoes of tomorrow
and the difference is that he decided
that if you buy a pair of shoes a kid in
a developing country or a person who's
in need is going to get a pair of shoes
so if any of you received the Box you
get the shoes there's a little flag on
top of it there's a little note that
says thank you for donating a pair of
shoes that's why TOMS are better or
different than other canvas shoes around
it's how they told the story it's
inspiring it's authentic it's solving a
problem it's rich in detail and it's a
story that only Blake can tell Spanx
Sara baked Blakely she was here about a
year ago she's a big hero of mine any
woman over 30 thanks thanks so what Sara
says with her story is never
underestimate a woman who wants her butt
to look good in a pair of pants and her
story is she was trying on those white
pants and she didn't like the way her
butt looked she took a pair of support
hose and she cut off the pantyhose part
and just put the little support part on
and she looked so much better why isn't
there a product like that so she took
five thousand dollars of savings that
she had gotten from selling fax machines
door-to-door and she made a prototype
and she said everybody was saying oh my
god what are you doing and she cold
called and went to buyers and she was
finally at Neiman Marcus and she saw
that the buyer was losing interest so
she took the buyer by the hand took her
took her into the bathroom and tried on
her prototype under the white pants and
the buyer said I'll take 3000 and that
was the beginning again
her story is very relatable she's
solving a problem it's rich in detail
and only Sarah can tell that story
bombas I picked this because I am being
bombarded by bombas I don't know if any
of you are but the ads
I'm up on my TV and on my computer and I
get mailings but this is like TOMS shoes
on steroids
take a look at this story of the
greatest sock never sold it's not for
sale in any stores and you can't buy it
online but somehow we just shipped our
ten million pair you may be wondering
who makes the sock that no one can buy
I'm Randy and I'm Dave and we're Bob's
socks are the number one most requested
clothing item of homeless shelters so
for every pair of super comfortable
bomba socks you buy we donate this pair
to someone who needs they're
specifically designed to meet the needs
of the homeless community with
reinforced seams and antimicrobial
treatment in darker colors to show less
visible wear and thanks to your
purchases and support we just donated
our 10 millionth pair to shelters around
the country it's these 10 million small
acts of human kindness that make this
the greatest sock never sold give a pair
when you buy a pair at bombas com what I
love about that is the story it tells
we've met Randy and Dave right we know
why they care they care about the
homeless we know what makes their socks
differentiated and the story they tell
is very powerful which is why their
campaign has been so successful when I
have a student who tells me that she's
been in the military and tells me about
her experiences I automatically
understand the context I say this is a
disciplined person this is someone who's
probably a leader this is someone who
knows how to take orders and knows how
to give orders this is someone who
probably knows how to present herself
well and this is a person who's good
with with delivering results she doesn't
have to list all those qualities for me
but if she tells me a story I'm going to
Intuit that just from her story and her
narrative if I have a student who was in
the Olympic swimming which I have you
know this is what I already know
I know that they are goal oriented I
know they've sacrificed I know that
they're used to performing while other
people watch them and I know that they
they are so determined to reach that
goal so what you want to do is to
increase your reputation
your executive presence in your personal
branding is to figure out what in your
story is going to give these clues to
people about who you are I really
believe you should have five stories in
your pocket and what that means is five
stories that you can pull out at
different times in your life that can
illustrate who you are what your values
are what they mean I remember that when
I came out here 20 years ago when I was
trying to start a website the CEO said
to me Allison can you tell me if a time
when you overcame something and that was
the first time I told my car accident
story and it would just came from my gut
and you know what she had been in a
motorcycle accident so we completely
bonded over that and I swear I think
that's what got me the job she's like I
want someone who'll tie up her leg to
work for me so a few months ago I went
to Qualtrics which is a switch's a big
conference and I got to see three of my
idols
Oprah Obama and Sir Richard Branson but
in between these presentations someone
else came on stage who by a show of
hands knows Billy McDermott great that
was exactly what I was hoping I didn't
know him either okay he's the CEO of sa
P and he comes out and he looks really
handsome and slick he's got the gray and
salt-and-pepper gray hair and he has
these sunglasses and so while he's just
sent all I can think of his why isn't
this guy removing his sunglasses it's
kind of slick and kind of smarmy and I
am so distracted that I don't listen to
anything that is being said in this
interview
I'm just hating on him so I pull out my
my cell phone which I really try not to
do because it's so rude just telling you
and and I look him up and it says that
about seven eight years ago he was
walking down the stairs carrying a glass
of water he fell and a shard of glass
went into his left eye he had all these
surgeries and lost his eye so obviously
he wears glasses now I am sure that
Billy does not want to tell this story
every single time he goes somewhere new
but it's very important to know your
audience and because he didn't tell me
his narrative I made all these
assumptions about him what I would have
suggested if I had been coaching him
would have been before he started
answering Ryan's question who was the
host to say oh by the way everybody
I've had some surgeries on my eye I need
to wear glasses don't worry I'm not
giving you any shade something like that
and you know what would have happened
then it would have been a non-issue I
wouldn't have been focusing on it and I
could have concentrated on his message
so to me it's really important to
anticipate pushback and to think how is
the audience going to take this
information in if you are presenting an
idea if you are telling a story think
about where someone might be skeptical
or someone might say hey that doesn't
work for me
or I don't really understand and then
build in the answers ahead of time into
your narrative be proactive so that no
one RV no one's gonna fill in the gaps
for you
you're gonna control your own narrative
so Amy Cuddy who's famous for the power
pose wrote this book presence and there
was a study in this book which I really
loved
which is about a bunch of groups of
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
funding from VCS what the study said was
that the entrepreneurs who showed
emotion told a story we're more
personable used humor had facial
expressions expressions those were the
ones who got the funding the ones who
just talked about data and showed graphs
and what kind of linear did not get the
funding what does that tell you it tells
you that people want to connect that
they want to understand why you're doing
what you're doing that they want to like
you and it's really important and that's
all about how you tell your story so I
was sent to the Missouri floods with
Good Morning America sounds like if Good
Morning America is trying to kill me
doesn't it so he sent me to cover the
floods in Missouri and my first day I
had to get in a helicopter with my crew
and take b-roll or footage and all I saw
were these these houses with their tips
just above the water and it was really
horrifying and then my assignment was to
go to the Red Cross shelter and find a
family that would be willing to go back
to their house and try to rescue either
their pets or their personal belongings
so after I shot the b-roll I went to the
Red Cross shelter and I found a head of
the fire department I said can I borrow
a boat for my crew so we can go and take
it back to one of the houses and he said
sure then I had to go find someone
so I went I saw this man standing
against the wall and his family was a
little bit off to the side and I went up
to him and I said hi I'm Alison Kluger
I'm from Good Morning America and I said
I have a boat and I have a crew and
would you be interested in coming back
with us and seeing if we can rescue
anything from your house well he just
started screaming at me he's like how
dare you how exploitive are you this has
been the worst time of my life this is a
complete tragedy and you're gonna fly
out of here in three days and go back to
your warm house and I'm gonna be here
homeless he says this is just the worst
time and and I just stood there and I
took it and I felt horrible and when he
was done telling me his story I put my
hand on his arm and I said I am so sorry
you're absolutely right and forgive me
if I have caused you any more grief
during this terrible time in your life
please accept my apology god bless you
and I walked away
two minutes later there's a tap on my
shoulder so how would it work with the
boat storytelling goes both ways
he needed to tell me his story I needed
to hear it it put everything in
perspective the empathy I showed the
connection he felt to me made him feel
safe we ended up taking him back to his
house he rescued belongings it was a
great piece and he was actually very
happy about it
communicating effectively needs all four
of these elements connection of some
sort off anticipate and then your
presence being very present I always say
that making a first impression is not a
choice it's strategic and I see some of
my students nodding you can make three
impressions positive neutral or negative
to make a negative first impression you
have to try you want to be controversial
you want to be obnoxious
but for the most part people opt for the
neutral impression you go to a meeting
you go to a cocktail party you go to an
off-site you go to a gathering and you
really want to be home watching game
Thrones with Devin I know I do but what
I look about it is it's an opportunity
not only to connect but to create
possibilities for you so when you go
there there needs to be some
self-awareness I believe that your brand
and your reputation are tied into your
executive presence and how you show up
to me your reputation is an echo that
precedes you into the room before you
even get there it can do the work for
you oh my gosh you need to meet Matt
he's awesome he's one of the smartest
people I know and he's doing this
project and you're gonna love him but
it's also what remains after you leave
and the little murmurs so you're
basically saying what is left behind for
people to remember do they want to
remember that you were a good person or
a value-add person or a funny person or
a helpful person and what impression
remains long after you've left you may
not know initially however somebody
might come up to you and say I remember
the first time I met you and here you
are at Reunion Weekend and there's gonna
be a lot of that going up to old friends
and saying I remember you the first time
I met you in that class
that's reputational currency if people
have something great to remember you by
how did you treat people did you look at
them did you connect with them when you
talked were you very present or were you
looking over their shoulder to see who
else is better coming into the room what
did you say
did you just gossip did you just shoot
the or did you add value how can I
help you with that project who can I
connect you with that you might know I
really admire what you just did to whom
did you talk to did you only talk to the
people who can help you did you only
talk to the people who you know or did
you recognize someone sitting on the
fringe by themselves and you welcomed
them in and have a conversation they'll
never forget you and how did you say it
when you talk are you talking really
really fast and you're just overwhelming
them and they just want you to shut up
or are you really present in the
conversation
so these are all elements of your brand
your reputation your executive presence
and storytelling can help you connect
how was received you may not hear it
till you come back to this reunion but
you might hear from someone who calls
you and says my friend met you and I
want to meet you for this this venture
executive presence is basically made up
of 20% of what people see right away
it's a sliver and what's unfair they can
we use this iceberg analogy is that
you're feeling judged on only 20% of who
you are the rest of it's under the war
to the 80% but not a lot of people have
time to spend getting to know that 80%
of you so what do you need to know well
you need to know that they're gonna be
judging you and some things that don't
have to do with your intelligence your
skills or your experience they're gonna
make a snap judgment but the good news
is you can control that so they're gonna
judge you in your appearance and I'm not
talking about being a supermodel I'm
talking about being appropriately
dressed or dressed with power or dressed
for the occasion or dressed in a way
that signals your brand your
communication skills for sure can you
connect all the things we just talked
about and your gravitas
so I usually show a picture of a swan
and I say what does that remind you of
and most people say elegance calmness
but the Swan has the little webbed feet
underneath the water paddling furiously
gravitas is being the Swan and not
letting people see your feet it's
basically saying I got this I can take
care of this you're safe with me and
that's a very important element of
executive presence this is what they're
gonna see in that sliver the first three
gender age ethnic background you can't
change but the last four you can you can
control your posture and how you stand
you can control your appearance you can
control your eye contact and you can
control how you talk to people and I
feel like your presence can be your most
powerful tool so now you're probably
thinking oh my god I'm exhausted does
this mean every time I go into a new
area I have to be so aware
got to stand a certain way dress a
certain way and if I'm doing this
am I really authentic it's a good
question isn't it well when I was at
Good Morning America my first two months
there I was crying at work and it wasn't
about something to do with work it was
personal and this producer Sonja Selby
right who was small and English and
terrifying pulled me into her office and
she said Alison I don't want to ever see
you crying again at work do you
understand why and I intuitively I knew
I and I said uh-huh and she said but she
told me anyway she said because you're
young you're attractive and you're
female and no one is going to think
you're reliable and no one is going to
give you any responsibility and no one
is gonna think you're capable of doing
the job you want to do do you understand
I'm like who and she said so if you're
having if you want to cry come into my
office and close the door but if someone
says to you how's your day you say I'm
having a great day thanks so much now
get the hell out of here and she slammed
the door and what do you think I want to
do cry
but I didn't have an office then so I
couldn't cry but this was the most
impactful lesson in my life
because what it told me is I wanted to
be seen as reliable I wanted to have
responsibility I wanted people to think
I was capable so then I decided well I
better act that way so I developed a
reputation for being unflappable for
getting along with people for being
easygoing for multitasking and the funny
thing is in TV I went to all these jobs
that were so high pressure being on air
being on live TV being in the control
room where anything could go wrong at a
minutes notice but I was able to handle
it and so the question of authenticity
is when you practice something every day
it becomes authentic to you so it
doesn't matter where you are right now
if there's a way that you want to be you
can just tweak it and you can start
doing it every day and then it becomes
authentic to you
so for you I say act like the leader
that you want to be and maybe there's
someone around you who's a role model
who you think handles everything really
well what is it about that leader that
you like can you emulate it maybe you're
someone who's always late
maybe you should show up on time and
keep doing that right maybe you don't
talk as much in meetings force yourself
to say one thing at each meeting
maybe you volunteer to give a seminar or
take on some new responsibilities but
starting to do something different will
help you take it more naturally so I
teach this course that I created called
strategic pivoting for your next chapter
and I teach it with Alex Rodriguez a-rod
who's our featured guest speaker and I'm
so happy he joined me because he's
someone who is strategically pivoted
through his life from a baseball icon to
philanthropist and investor a host
commentator and he's been very strategic
about it what I loved about this class
is I used this book by Jenny Blake
called pivot and she has a framework
that is so easy to learn and a lot of it
does involve your narrative but these
are the four steps it's
ants can pilot and launch planting means
you just assess who are you what are you
good at because whatever you pivot into
you're gonna take the same skills with
you
you're not gonna reinvent the wheel even
if it's a completely new area there's
still a part of you that is responding
to this area because of the talents and
the strengths you already have the next
step which is plant is figuring out
where your knowledge gaps and how do you
fill them do you take a course do you
take a seminar do you shadow someone do
you offer to intern somewhere
do you have dinners with people who can
help you and guide you you also have to
figure out how to broadcast your new
direction because if you want to pivot
if you don't tell people they're not
going to be able to help you so it's
important to figure out how are you
gonna broadcast this change are you
going to have a small dinner and tell
people this is what I plan to do are you
going to send out an email you're gonna
make a little video whatever it is or
put it on social media you've got to let
people know what you're doing so that
they can help you and you also have to
learn how to tell your story about it
finally there's piloting small little
incremental experiments to see if it
fits if it feels good so and the purpose
really is to get data so you might fail
it may not go the way you want this is
what beta testing is right but it's a
good idea to at least try it do you have
a financial runway have you figured it
out there ways to also do this you can
go on Craigslist or one of these other
sites where you say I'd like to do a
project for a very low price and someone
will hire you to try your side hustle
and then you can leverage that for your
pivot lots of creative ways to to step
into your pivot and then finally you
launch but there's a lot of iteration
and reiteration of those three steps
before you actually launch your new
direction this is hard to read but I'm
putting this up because this is an
actual letter that I received from one
of my friends he wanted to pivot and he
sent me this email and I was bcc'd so I
know that he sent it to tons of people
basically saying what his talents were
as a CEO what he was looking for what
he's done but the last line please feel
free to share my CV with appropriate
parties and I can be reached at my cell
he did exactly what you need to do
because every
and I see something that could fit him I
send it his way if he hadn't done this
how would I know it's important to use
your origin story to create your own
narrative we did Tom's we did Sarah I'm
gonna talk about mine a little bit even
though Devon filled you in new york city
girl went to Penn I always worked at TV
stations on my free time hired at Good
Morning America three days after
graduation I stayed there for eight
years I was promoted three times within
went to a lot of disaster zones they
didn't kill me and after eight years I
hit my proverbial ceiling so then I was
invited to go to q2 which is part of QVC
it was started by Barry Diller and Diane
von Furstenberg and it was a Home
Shopping Network I really thought that
was it for me in my career I'm going
into cheese ville but they paid me twice
as much money and so I went the host
quit I was going there to produce all
the home products and they said you go
on air I was like oh but then I realized
what are my skills what have I been
doing for eight years I've been coaching
people to be on TV I've been helping
them message I've been helping them tell
their story so I went on air and I would
do four hours of TV a day and I would
sell twenty items in each hour and this
is where I honed my storytelling skills
I had to convince people to buy a a
barbecue or a pot or a gardening gnome
and I'm telling you that's challenging
so you have to demonstrate and tell a
story it was the best education I ever
had on how to message and then they hide
they got a new host and I went into the
control room where I wanted to be this
was awesome for me I got to control the
whole show all the talent wanted me to
produce them because I had been a talent
and I knew how to talk to them in their
ear I was gentle I was encouraging all
the things I wanted someone to be for me
but this was awesome because I got to
figure out if something was selling if
something wasn't how I would I'm in the
moment switch the show around again
another great education and then I went
to a new shopping network called GSN it
was 16 hours of live television I was
the executive producer I hired people
fired them I managed a hundred people I
created new shows and I became kind of
the face of the network and I did these
promos where I have to
cinge in 30 seconds what something was
about to take a look and I now listen
Kluger your host for designers Corning
here at GSN we get New York City
designers to bringing their jewelry and
all the jewelry is like a piece of art
each one is handcrafted semi-precious
stones unique design and you can't find
it anywhere else you don't have to
wander around the streets downtown
looking for that very special piece of
jewelry we're gonna bring it to you
we're gonna bring you the piece of
jewelry that's beautiful interesting
that you can't find anywhere else with
the price that you can afford so be sure
to catch me here at TSN the smart
shoppers Channel right thank you so
cheesy but I bet some of you want that
piece of jewelry don't you I know you do
I actually still own that so after I
worked there the view came calling and
now I'm back at ABC at higher stakes I'm
in the control room with Barbara in my
ear and Starr and Meredith and Lisa Ling
and Debbie Matenopoulos and this was a
dream job and I really enjoyed it but
then my husband who's sitting right
there wanted to go to Stanford Graduate
School of Business
he made me move and I left the best job
and I came here I started nothing
don't be embarrassed honey and I started
up a website for women and we work on
disaster a year later and then open TV
snapped me up because when you fail you
really succeed and I was executive
producer of interactive applications all
of these jobs tapped into my television
skills and the story that I'd always
tell is how to create great content how
to coach people so didn't matter where I
was going in my pivots and I would
adjust my story but I'd still focus in
on what my strengths were and then I
worked with out for a year and helped
him start up Current TV and it was
really an amazing opportunity to work
with him the day that I finished my
consultancy I found out I was pregnant
after nine in vitro and I stayed home
for seven years and I raised trouble and
more trouble trouble more troubles right
there hyper more trouble and and then I
also did some Media Consulting on the
side just to keep my foot in the door
but I
to tell you that for seven years I
really didn't work that much so then I
came to this which I'm sure a lot of you
can play chew what the hell am I gonna
do Who am I what is my story and I was
like I don't want to go back and do all
the same things but I had to just
repackage myself and so this is what I
did I figured out well what's my
narrative what are my strengths those
are the things I do really well I coach
people I create innovative content I
message effectively I present publicly
and I'm great across all different
platforms so I had to repackage myself
and I came up with a proposal of a
course I want to teach here and I my
husband sent my proposal to one of his
professors he introduced me to JD Schrom
who we all know worship and love and JD
said I'll take a chance on you and we
created reputation management strategies
for successful communicators and
teaching it for the sixth year now when
I finished the thank you thank you
under that under then I was invited to
co-teach to teach a communication under
that umbrella
I developed electives for media training
executive presence for women and then
Tyra came so I was sitting right there
and seat 110 and Tyra was here talking
about her life and her personal brand
and she talked about how she pivoted
from being a supermodel on the runway to
getting curvy and being a Victoria's
Secret model to being the first African
African American model on the cover of
Sports Illustrated it's being an actress
to being an author to being a roving
reporter for Oprah to having her own
talk show called the Tyra's show then
from developing and creating america's
next top model which had 23 cycles going
to Harvard for a nine week OPM degree
and then creating Tyra Beauty just some
of the things she did I'm sitting there
my brains going crazy I'm learning so
much about personal branding I'm
thinking I've got to teach with her so
when the when it's over I go backstage
and there's a guard and I say hi I'd
like to go in and he said and he said
you're not allowed in here I saw no no I
am I said I teach here and I used to
produce the view in Good Morning America
and Tyra's been on those shows boom let
me in very short narrative but it worked
and I go in and I meet Tyre and I just
give her my short spiel our narrative
I'm like Tyra I'm a television producer
by trade I produced Good Morning America
in the view I teach here now and I
listen to you and in that hour I learned
more about personal branding that I have
ever learned before and I have an idea
of wanting to teach a compress course
with you would you be interested and
fortunately her agent was there she was
she gave me if their number we made a
phone call for the next week and in that
week I just started putting that
proposal together and I said to myself
how am I going to make this course
really serve my students how is it going
to be innovative I'm gonna stream it
live on Facebook we're gonna come live
out of a television station I'm gonna
have to what can Tyra add to it who are
the guests that we're going to book so I
had everything in order when I called
her I had all the dates for compressed
courses available I had all six classes
already kind of fashioned down I said
Tyra what do you want to do what do you
want to teach in this she
gave me all these great ideas we
collaborated and then I went back and
redid the proposal then I went to the
assistant dean of the business school
and I said to him I want to teach a
course of Tyra Banks this is why it's
going to be this is why it's going to be
great this is why it's going to be
innovative this is how we're gonna serve
our students this is what they're gonna
learn from it Tyra is committed for
either this two weeks or this two weeks
she's going to be there for all six
classes we're gonna come live out of a
television studio we're gonna do life
we're gonna stream live on Facebook and
I just told my narrative and I explained
my vision through my story and he said
yes now I'm gonna say something if I had
gone to him the day after Tyra and said
you know I think I'd like to teach with
Tyra Banks I know in my heart the
categorically the answer would have been
no because people would say that's not
the brand here we don't want Tyra
teaching here but I knew she was an
amazing businesswoman and educator and
she proved it out we just finished
teaching project you for the third year
in a row and this is my secret weapon
when you're creating a narrative present
the solution not the suggestion remember
what I said about anticipating pushback
I anticipated everything the Dean might
say to me we don't do this I know you
don't but that's why it's gonna be great
Tyra is a supermom no she's not she's a
businesswoman look what he's created
everything that I was expecting I got
but I had an answer for it so when
you're creating your story in your
narrative think about anticipating what
someone can say and then come up with
the answers ahead of time and there's
time I'm the one on the left that's Tyra
in our first year and that was us just a
few weeks ago in the TV station and
she's gonna come back next year so what
does a narrative sound like well I'm
gonna share it with you high two classes
where the final project in strategic
pivoting for your next chapter and
project you my students had to come up
with in either two minute or one a
minute and a half pitch so for strategic
pivoting they have to tell me who they
are where they come from what their
talents are where
want to pivot to and why they're gonna
be great so let's go take a look at one
of my students and what he did for his
pitch hi everyone
my name is Thomas and as the accent may
already have given away I'm originally
from the UK prior to coming here to
Stanford Business School I worked in
London in private equity I'm here today
to talk about my pivot to social impact
and specifically within that to impact
investing which I think brings those two
things together perfectly my passion for
social impact started when I had the
experience of speaking of my
grandfather's funeral that day as I
stepped up to the lectern and I looked
out at hundreds of faces I realized what
it is to live a fulfilling life and it's
to make a positive impact on the lives
of people you touch as I ask myself what
is it all add up to that is what I hold
in my mind how can I make sure every
interaction I have positively changes
the lives of others I think I'm set up
to be a great impact investor because
I'm a fast learner and I'm extremely
adventurous in my prior roles I've had
to learn about industries I hadn't even
heard of and just weeks later be an
expert in investing we covered such a
range of sectors from asset to waste
management and my adventurous side keeps
me take going to new cultures and new
places all the time I love nothing more
than connecting with people
understanding what drives them and what
makes their cultures so special I
believe these skills will enable me to
venture into developing markets where
they could benefit so fundamentally from
fresh financial capital which will give
them future economic prosperity I've
been fortunate to already start to pilot
this change in my life this summer I
spent three months in Israel and then
Kenya and I got to be really excited
about going to work every day with a
purpose we were trying to empower rural
farmers in Kenya and trying to redefine
the financial market in Israel and that
purpose is what I want to carry with me
through my life so as I now think about
what does it all add up to its that how
do I make a positive impact on the lives
of others for the rest of my career
thank you very much and I look forward
to all of your comments so the next part
which I'm not showing you is where I
give him feedback on his
munication skills Alex gave and feedback
on the business idea of what he wants to
do and Jenny Blake the author of pivot
talked about how he used the frameworks
from art from the book and what I love
about this it's only two minutes it
might have seemed longer but he's gonna
use this narrative in a lot of different
iterations he'll shorten it
he'll tweak it he'll edit it and he will
focus on certain areas of it depending
on his audience but he knows now how to
give his narrative he we knew his origin
story we knew he's adventurous we knew
why he cares about social impact and we
know what he wants to do and now that he
can express it it's going to be easier
to take his story and pass it on let's
take a look at one more this is from
project G with Tyra and this is one of
my students Nancy
[Laughter]
hi I'm Nancy and I love to live life out
loud from the necklaces I love to rock
to the melon and I proudly wear on my
skin color and vibrancy is such a huge
part of who I am
but it hasn't always been that way I was
born with a disability in my arm in my
spinal called conky's palsy before I
even knew my name doctors put limits on
what I could achieve and they told my
parents I could never live independently
but I refused to believe that and I
rebelled
I saw how vibrant I could be and I grew
up passion for helping other people see
that their own vibrancy through
photography photography has shown me
that I'm so much bigger than this body
and it's allowed me to connect with
people in deep and intimate ways I built
my company a kostenko to share the
stories of women of color it's in my
absolute honor to share their vibrancy
with the world and it's my big hairy
scary dream to take this company from
being about photography to a lifestyle
brand think cookware and interior design
but designed with the needs and wants of
women in color in mind I want to help
other women expose their true color in
every aspect of their lives
that pitch to me had everything we
learned so much about Nancy in a minute
and a half we know that she's overcome
adversity we know what she wanted to do
in her life we know why she wants to do
it and you can see all the strengths and
unique characteristics and she presents
so beautifully
she knows her story from beginning to
end and I feel so confident that anyone
who sees that would want to hire her and
I feel confident that she's gonna
absolutely accomplish what she sets out
to do and that was the power of her
story and her narrative and she
controlled it beautifully so I'm just
gonna take a moment and read this this
was one one little paragraph I got from
the final papers and it really says
everything once we understand our
substance we can then create a
compelling narrative around it one that
excites compels and explains who we are
watching everyone's final pitches on the
last day of class has shown me firsthand
the remarkable power of a good story in
sharing their journeys I was able to
understand the logic of their passions
and I immediately felt closer to them
through storytelling we are able to
offer more facets of ourselves for
others to connect with and in doing so
we can build trust and understanding I'm
gonna have her write my first book
review because that really encapsulates
what the whole point of the course was
about and what I really believe in
controlling your narrative connecting to
people so whether you realize it or not
I had five stories in my pocket today
and I shared them all with you one of
them was about the field of dreams which
told you a lot about almost a foolish
risky thing I did when I was younger but
how I overcame it and then the Missouri
floods where I learned how important
human connection is and storytelling
goes both ways Sonya who taught me to be
the leader than I need to be and want to
be and show up every day being
consistent
I've talked about pivoting from media to
education and how you can leverage all
your natural talents in one area and
bring them to another and I had the
connection between media and education
how it worked and then finally everybody
wants to know how Tyra got here so I had
to tell you how I got here
the most important thing is I'm hoping
after this time do you have a sense of
Who I am then you know who I am and why
I care about what I do and what what
differentiates me from other people and
you know more about my credibility and
you feel more connected to me and that
I've convinced you how important is to
own your narrative what are your five
stories thank you
does anyone have any questions Spencer
Smith class of 2009 you talked about how
stories go both ways in the example of
the Missouri floods and the reaction you
got from the man when you walked up to
him to make an ask coming out of that
have you thought about how do you
solicit someone's story ahead of time so
that they don't have an explosive
reaction necessarily but that you can
have that one-on-one to get their story
hear from them and then be able to tell
your story to connect with them it's a
great question and it goes back to
anticipating the push back if I had been
more experienced and had even thought
about it a little bit more I would have
approached him in a different way I
would have said I know this is probably
the worst time in your life and you
don't want to talk to me right now I
said I'm here to do a piece and I really
actually want to help you and I've got a
boat and if it would help you in any way
during this terrible time would you like
to go back and take a look at your house
and see if you can rescue things I know
you've got so much on your mind and this
may be the last thing you want to do but
if this in any way can aid you I would
love to be part of that solution now
I've learned that how to approach people
but it's knowing your audience ahead of
time doing some research and again
anticipating how they might react to
your content it's using your emotional
intelligence and taking a little bit of
time to prep hope that helped in the
process of pivoting to the next step
of your life what there are moments when
you doubted yourself and whether there
were fear of the uncertainties in the
future and how did you handle those
emotions thank you for the question I
doubted myself every single step of the
way
I had impostor syndrome with every
single job I was waiting to be found out
I hated my husband on many occasions for
pushing me out of my comfort zone and
what I say to people is that double down
on what you know you're good at and it's
how you tell your narrative so if you're
pivoting and people say well you came
from there you know that's totally
disconnected to where you want to go and
you say I know that I did this for this
reason and then you tell a story and you
say I know what I realized for these
years is it's not fulfilling this
passion I have inside of me but these
skills that I learned here are going to
be so helpful and informative as I move
into this new area and I'm gonna be even
better at this job with you because of
this experience so a lot of it is how
you change your narrative and for me a
lot of it was knowing my audience and
saying I'm going into this new area I'm
telling you when I went into the website
into digital I was just like I'm not a
technical person I just play one on TV
I don't know anything but I was really
good at managing people I was good at
asking questions I was little good at
research so I would double down and what
I was good at and the things I didn't I
would help fill the knowledge gaps with
asking for help being really transparent
or going into my office crying and then
figuring it out I hope that helps
anybody else thank you so much I'm Paul
Jay and class of 2014 I loved first half
of my life in China second half of my
life in America and the tension between
these two countries is making me feel
confused at us and depressed at worse
how do you tell your story in a larger
context where people increasingly hate
each other thank you that's a really big
question and so and I'm gonna try to
answer that thoughtfully I had a talk
with one of my alums this morning about
culture
differences and assumptions right Matt
and this is what I believe it's all
about connection and finding common
ground so small talk is important asking
questions is important and being
transparent is important so when you're
going up against somebody who maybe is
from a different culture or is coming
with stereo stereotypes of you it's your
job to tell your story in a way that
shows empathy and understanding and
credibility again assuming that they
might have pushback so saying you know
you might not trust me so much I'm from
America we seem very mercenary you know
we don't value this things but the truth
is I come from I come from here as well
and that's part of who I am and part of
my DNA and what I've learned in America
is this so I can I can put both of these
together and be this hybrid and be even
effective in America and in China so
again it's how do you twist your story
in a positive way to show your empathy
your trustworthiness your credibility
but it's about building bridges it's
about finding a common ground and asking
them about it or sharing and also being
vulnerable thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]